[Musique]
et ben écoute mon petit jean-michel si
tu veux tu peux le coach et mon gamin
pourrez y trouver une gonzesse
par contre c'est un sport qu'il ya du
boulot facile tonnerre à vue tout à la
sphère réelle qu'il faut lever coach
émeut d'autant à ranger avant cancun
film plaît ma mère une amie passé
surveille
moi je suis une fan de johnny hallyday
il m'a beaucoup de montées que je
l'adorais ce monsieur l'a d'abord et
cinq ans qu'a tenue puis l'a jamais dit
du mal de personnes par exemple
j'adorais ça soit son préféré c'est
vivre pour le meilleur de se vouloir ou
tout ça donnait bien riche et ne rien
garder que l'amour et l'amour que vous
franchement de ville quand il s'agace me
fait penser à ma mère oui c'est vrai que
ça me choque ça me dérange un peu près
d'haïti le nouveau champ de bataille
et puis la finale il est un joli dos à
la même crainte deux jours à mon avis
c'est moins bon cyril salat même crème
de jour comme moi comme tu es là ne vont
peut être pas le coin il fera idées
pareilles rapport et ne pas y répondre à
la 6e' nancy
[Musique]